The long wait for Avengers: Endgame is almost
over, and if its test audiences are any indication,
it'll be well worth it.
In a recent conversation with BoxOfficePro.com,
co-director Joe Russo revealed that the final
film in the Infinity Saga has scored perhaps
the best reception of any MCU film to date,
which, of course, is no small feat.
Like all tentpole films, each new MCU entry
is put through a gauntlet of test audiences
before it hits your local multiplex.
Russo explained that these screenings are
often used to fine-tune certain scenes, tweak
certain elements of the plot, or streamline
the narrative.
"We try to create a density in storytelling
that makes [each film] feel compulsive.
We're very rigorous about storytelling points,
and we spend months in the edit room twisting
and turning the narrative a bunch of different
ways until we think we've unlocked the best
one.
We're vigilant about using test audiences
to tell us whether we're on the right track
or we're making bad decisions.
With Endgame, it had one of the most incredible
audience responses in Marvel history.
Irrespective of the length, it's been consistently
embraced by the test audiences."
To put that in perspective, consider that
MCU flicks tend to fare very well with these
audiences in general, and more than one recent
entry has completely blown crowds away at
early screenings.
Captain Marvel, for example, was heralded
as one of the best films in the entirety of
the MCU, while 2017's Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2 received a perfect score of 100 from
its test audiences, which is virtually unheard
of.
It goes without saying that expectations are
sky high for Endgame, which will put a cap
on an overarching narrative spanning eleven
years, 22 films, and dozens of individual
character arcs.
Yet, at least as far as test audiences are
concerned, it seems to have more than met
those expectations.
So how did brothers Joe and Anthony Russo
manage such a massively complex undertaking?
It turns out their entire careers have prepared
them for this moment.
Not only have they already helmed three of
the MCU's most challenging ensembles with
Captain America: The Winter Soldier, Captain
America: Civil War, and Avengers: Infinity
War, but prior to joining Marvel, they earned
a reputation for deftly weaving complicated
storylines on the cult classic sitcoms Arrested
Development and Community.
Joe Russo told BoxOfficePro,
"We spent a decade squeezing complex comedy
stories with many, many characters, both of
those shows being big ensemble shows, into
21 minutes.
We'd call it 'the Russo path,' where we came
in and squeezed it down to a density that
we felt would elevate the show, because it
would move so quickly that you'd miss half
the jokes and have to watch it again.
That was an agenda of ours.
The same thing is true when we work on these
Marvel films."
It's a method that has worked out pretty well
for the filmmaking pair.
But while it's been speculated that Endgame
could constitute their MCU swan song, Russo
isn't ready to make that call just yet.
"The door is always open.
Everyone at Marvel is like family to us.
We grew up reading comic books, and these
stories are incredibly open to us.
Anything that moved you as a child or spoke
to you as a child has an emotional resonance
you carry with you your entire life.
It's very hard to find a story that can speak
to you the same way it did when you were younger."
"I keep telling everybody they should move
on.
Some do.
But not us."
It goes without saying that fans across the
board would love to see the Russos continue
on in the MCU, but if they end up departing
after Endgame, it looks like they'll be going
out with a bang.
And in case the rapturous reception from test
audiences isn't enough to convince you, consider
the reaction of Captain America himself.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
the star was nearly at a loss for words when
asked to describe his Endgame viewing experience,
finally saying,
"Man, this one's really good.
I choked up like three times."
All of which is to say: buckle up, true believers.
Avengers: Endgame is nothing less than the
culmination of the single most ambitious feat
of storytelling in cinematic history, and
all signs point to Mighty Marvel having completely
nailed it.
We'll get to see for ourselves just how hard
when the flick hits screens on April 26.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.